great stuff so look these uh results
today much better than the market
expected uh
how much of that is down to what you
would describe as self-help and how much
has it been flattered by stronger oil
and gas prices in the quarter
well ian thanks for having me on they
are a good set of results um clearly
financially a strong set of earnings but
importantly i think a strong set of uh
of cash numbers uh we talk in 11 billion
dollars of cash in the quarter that's
about
six from operations and about five from
divestment proceeds and what that's
enabled us to do is get our net debt
down about a year
ahead of schedule um down below our
target of 35 we're actually at 33.3
billion this morning that's down 18
billion dollars
from its peak in the pandemic and that's
allowed us then to start buybacks
and of course at the same time we've
made strategic progress so
the reasons why are it's been a we did
have an exceptional
quarter in gas trading the environment's
clearly been
helpful to us and the underlying
business is performing
uh very well castrol for example had a
very good quarter so
it is down to the hard work that the
team has done over the last 12
months focused on the balance sheet
focused on cost focused on capital
focused on bringing those projects
online as you say net debt down by 5.6
billion to 33.3 billion
the market's been very concerned about
debt levels do you think this is going
to be enough to put to bed those worries
well i think it's a i think today is a
real milestone in that regard we have
as i said down 5.6 billion in the
quarter down 18 billion dollars from the
peak of 51 billion dollars last year
so it's been a step-by-step journey
focused on the basics of the business
and i do think it's a very strong signal
to the market
uh that net debt is very much going in
the right direction
what we've said ian is that we will
start buybacks in the second quarter
and that going forward for this year
we'll allocate 60
of any surplus cash to buybacks and we
will continue to take care of the
balance sheet allocating 40
of surplus cash to the balance sheet so
in a moderate environment we should
expect that
uh trajectory to continue now in june
last year unanimous plans to
cut 10 000 jobs globally how far along
the road are you in that process
well it's been a very painful process
obviously not least for those involved
and for all the people around them five
and a half thousand people
have left the company so far about
another two to three thousand will leave
this year and the remainder
will leave at the beginning of next year
uh great people who've dedicated their
their lives 30 to 40 years in many cases
to the company and
we obviously wish them well into the
future i think the good
news here ian is that the restructuring
is essentially behind us
we have done what we needed to do the
new organization is up and running
we're now focused on the business at
hand running the operations
running the marketing business and doing
the things that we need to do
to deliver shareholders what they want
which is a
competitive cash return which today
marks that milestone on the buybacks
while at the same time not a choice
while at the same time transitioning the
bp for the future now during the quarter
you and your partner spent nearly a
billion pounds on buying the rights to
develop two offshore wind sites
in the irish sea a lot of people thought
you overpaid for those assets
well not in the least and uh if i got a
a
pound or a penny for the people who have
since
wanted to come in and buy into what we
just won
um i think i'd be in a very good place
so
others seem to think that it was a very
good deal and are willing to put their
money
where their mouth is so to speak we're
not farming down those interests we're
very very pleased
it's a very different uh business to
what
was available on the the other side of
the uh
the british isles and in the same lease
round great location
great wind resource synergistic uh
blocks next to each other um hopefully
shorter licensing times because of the
the migratory bird patterns and so on
and so forth
so it's like the same house on a good
street and a not so good street
and you know it's going to cost you a
little bit more on the good street and
this is definitely a good street so i'm
very very pleased
that we were successful in that license
round uh and look forward to developing
um those leases in the months and years
ahead and hopefully creating a lot of
good jobs in the process
your opposite number at total has said
that he's concerned there's a bubble in
some renewable assets is there a danger
that people
are overpaying for some of these assets
look i i'm not going to comment on on
what others do all i can do is look at
what we do ourselves and
you know the more i learn about this
part of the industry and the more
convinced i am
that we have a lot to add to deliver the
sorts of return
promises that we've made our investors
eight to ten percent returns
these are 60-year leases lifetime of 60
years
this is stable cash flow for generations
in many many regards
and we can bring all of the experience
that we've learned in the offshore
hydrocarbon business and apply it to the
offshore wind business
we can use our supply chain organization
that we built up here in the uk over
decades
and importantly as we look at hydrogen
on the east coast we can
take that wind power and use it to to
maybe power the hydrogen facility
we have bp pulse here in the uk i think
the largest charging
ev charging business here in the uk we
can use the
uh the the electrons generated by the
offshore wind to power
our own charging business so when you
look at it in the round
it really is what we call an integrated
energy company strategy
in action yes you mentioned uh bp pulse
when will capex peak for this particular
part of the business
well i think we will continue to grow
this business as demand
grows over the coming years we will be
disciplined of course as we do that
but i'm very excited about it and we're
doing a lot of work on
on-the-go charging we're going to put
500 ultra-fast chargers this is where
you can get a 100 miles in 10 minutes
uh 150 kilowatts chargers in
in germany we're building out our
position here in the uk we got 10 000
charge points here in the uk
and in china ian we're partnered with
didi which is the world's largest
mobility provider 550 million users
30 million rides a day we've close to 2
000 charge points with dd
in in china they're the number one owner
of electric vehicles in the world so
we've just signed deals this past
quarter with the volkswagen group
to accelerate that rule out in europe
we've got deals with daimler
i'm very excited about this part of the
business as the world transitions
uh to evs as is happening now it's more
than a year since united's water
generally regarded as the most ambitious
plans by a traditional oil and gas
company to decarbonize
why do you think investors seem
skeptical about the strategy
well i think the interesting thing ian
and i'm very glad that we did what we
did
uh 12 months ago is is that society in
the world has moved
towards us rather than away from us uh
over the past 12 months and that just
continues to happen each and every
day whether it's the us rejoining paris
and then
ratcheting up its ndc ambitions
just last week whether it's china coming
out with a 26 target
this is going one direction and one
direction only and in the past 12 months
because of the ambition that we laid out
the world's coming together towards our
strategy rather than further away from
it
what investors i think have questioned
ian is can we deliver
competitive cash returns to them while
at the same time
transitioning the company and that's a
very fair question and today's results
i hope really put put that point
to bed we are delivering competitive
cash returns
18 billion net reduc reduction in net
debt means that we can now start
our buyback program 500 million dollars
in the second quarter
and at the same time over the coming
years we believe we can get those
distributions back to the pre-pandemic
levels
in a moderate price environment at the
same time
we're making progress on that strategy
so the question isn't
uh is one right or one wrong it's can
you do both at the same time
and i think today's results prove that
we can
now cop 26 is coming up later this year
in glasgow are there specific
outcomes that you would hope to see look
i think there are a number of things
that
uh that need to happen clearly um
we need to all ratchet up our ambitions
and you saw that with the climate summit
happening
in the u.s uh this past week but a few
other things that
i think are important and that would be
very helpful coming out of cop
one is that we need everyone on the
pitch ian
green companies low-carbon zero-carbon
companies are fantastic
but regardless of the growth rates
they're not going to solve the world's
problems what the world needs
is greening companies and by greening i
mean companies like bp who are carbon
intensive today but
who have net zero ambitions mark carney
says if you want to solve climate
go to where the emissions are well the
emissions are here we're transitioning
how do we encourage and support greening
companies that's one
the second is clearly it's all about the
developing world
how do we help them make these changes
that are so necessary
and thirdly obviously the holy grail
here is a global price on carbon
something that's very very difficult to
do but something that we've been
advocating for decades and in fact just
last week
in washington state in the united states
a bill has passed that we are
what we were advocated strongly for
which puts a price in carbon in that
state so
they're the sorts of things ian that
would be super helpful
out of uh cops cop 26. i mean you're
clearly very sincere about this i think
most of the other european operators are
as well what about those american plays
can you ever see them going green in the
same way
well look i think we all have different
strategies and i think you know
sometimes we
we we like to talk about a u.s and an
american divide
i don't think of it like that i think
that companies rightly have different
strategies
i can't comment on other people's
strategies i can only comment
on our own strategy and i have to say
that you know
each day with time i feel better and
better about the strategy that we've
chosen
i think investors every day are
beginning to understand that strategy
better and better and you've seen that i
think in our share price performance
from the beginning of this year so i've
got faith in what we're doing and others
will make the choices that they feel is
right for them
and a brief word please on supply and
demand uh
where you see it going in the next
quarter well look i think there's a lot
of uh
uncertainty out there just because uh
the us and the uk are
sort of coming out the pandemic does not
mean that the world is coming out of the
pandemic
we've got a humanitarian uh crisis in
india that you know
a lot about we've got 7 000 employees
there we just lost two employees in the
last
week so that's clearly the focus there
brazil we've also lost many many
employees there
so i think there is uncertainty on the
demand outlook but it is very strong
in america it's very strong in china and
of course
we've got the stabilizing influence of
opec who has both the capacity
and the desire it seems to hold the
market in that sort of 60 to 70 dollar
world so
lots of uncertainty as usual the
stabilizing influence of opec in the
background
we feel quite good about the outlook for
price
all right thanks very much indeed for
sparing the time to speak to us today
it's much appreciated
thank you